la grand place publique en tout adulte
sommeil à nantes et chambéry
tu vois que tout est très très limité
m
petit jules sitruk ses aveux les
invitations
c'est une façon de leur dire
souvenez-vous de ses rêves que vous
aviez enfants qu'est ce qu'ils sont
devenus quoi qu'est ce que vous en avez
fait et moi je trouve qu'on a tout
intérêt repartir dans l'enfance et
surtout à ne jamais la quitter
d'une certaine façon aux gamins qui ne
mâchent pas leurs mots je vous file la
fille de billy en partie dans les
aventures hautes en bonnet serbe a
engagé des parents évidemment équipé à
londres à des gros nibards des gros
nibards un tas d'idées vertes à des gros
nichons pour les chances qui m'a
beaucoup touché c'est que déjà ça parle
d'enfants ont des problèmes de famille
du coup j'ai déjà pensé un peu et ça
pouvait faire déjà après le film ça
aurait pu faire résonner quelques
quelques personnes ne pas mentir à leurs
parents ce genre de choses pourquoi des
poussées le reste allant au fonds
comment tu t'appelles de mon petit
coucou aux boules qui toi l'autorité des
grands signes de jimmy et ce manque de
respect qui est automatique chez les
adultes que je peux je déteste quoi
c'est pas parce qu on est plus jeune que
on n'est pas une personne à part entière
si les enfants sont pressés volcan c'est
parce qu'il en a marre d'être regardé
deux messieurs suis ému quand je n'avais
pas vu un piège que j'ai évité de faire
je leur ai parlé comme un des acteurs
comme les acteurs qui sont là sur un
plateau qui savent leur texte qui doit
jouer des situations et je leur donnais
des indications comme si j'avais à faire
de niro uma thurman et samuel jackson
absolue pour la vie